hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play lone
survivor
sorry for the delay in episodes of this
guys but I've been distracted with other
videos but I'm not giving up on this
series I'm definitely gonna be doing it
and so I have to be very careful and I
loaded this up before and there was a
problem because it said that I didn't
have a map for this area which is quite
incorrect because as I left off oh oh
that's not a good sign so you guys
didn't want me to load the Gamo up too
much but it doesn't even seem to make a
bit of difference in this area because
it's so damn dark so I need to be very
careful as I try to find the map and I
don't recall where it was uh because it
has been a while but our main objective
right now and it is dark in here who's
that on the floor I just saw now the
main objective for this area is to no
don't pull out your map what are you
doing you dick get back there son of a
[ __ ] okay so I believe no oh that's
yeah I'm being an idiot because I'm not
pressing the right buttons for this okay
that's where I came in I believe that
the map was off to the right but I miss
not certain where I wasn't mistaken I
thought it was in this room but
apparently it is not the only only the
mirrors in this room all right we got a
move we got a lot of ground to cover not
a lot of time we hope I crap okay you go
back into your corner and I need to go
down that hallway because I believe that
the map is down there epidote II but ow
doing a little dance back from knock
knock oh boy alright come on come on
there it is okay alright we got it got
it we got it alright pull it out we're
at that location but there was a hole in
between there and there so that we
couldn't get from here to there now you
guys said that I needed to take a lot
more pills when I was going to bed which
is really weird beer burger to be Oh
dad's not good ok so we got a guy in
there in the pill and or not a pill but
a hole in the ground over there that I
can't get through now how much rotting
meat do I have a 90 beat oh no oh no
no I was a mistake now how much I've got
I've got plenty of rotting meat so I'm
able to get away from these guys if need
be now the only question is what is this
oh yeah that's right there's I'm looking
for the generator which is down this
hallway but I still don't know if I'm
able to get down there through here I
believe that there's still something
else blocking my path although what it
is I'm not sure if I remember I was just
down here and there's a monster up here
is there a hidey hole somewhere oh he is
close okay definitely not going down
that way come on got to find a way
around there's a monster immediately
over here but what is this block from
the other side there's a buzzer right
there
god damn it there's so many places for
the monsters to be oh man I don't want
to shoot him because you guys have told
me that that's bad news bears but I may
not have much of a choice because I
don't see another way around him
it's just continually blocked off well
no matter where I go now I was able to
get around him a little bit over here
yeah let me see see what I'm dealing
with over here okay oh I definitely uh
don't want to shoot him but I may have
to oh no way you guys said I needed to
use the flares now what it does I don't
know oh well hello there what does that
do what does that do beside provide some
light oh and it went away okay so it's
very quick does it scare off the little
buggers I don't have any I don't have
mini to play with hey does hey that's
awesome oh that's so cool that makes
them all disoriented and junk so that
they can't move
alright you guys may have mentioned that
but I I wasn't paying attention enough
apparently yes all rusted shut that's
hardly fair
wait don't I have something that I can
do that with tools or something schizos
can opener a gun a bucket anything that
I can it's like that's a negatory
where is he good now all rusted beyond
repair what is this junk oh my god
Duncan [ __ ] that's what it is okay
so I gotta get through this guy I have
one flare left so might as well use it
now
Boosh suck on that [ __ ] yeah all right
now we can finally make it to the
generator area Locke need a key to open
it Oh oh come on you gotta be kidding me
no oh no oh wait no that's the opposite
way that's right okay huh I was worried
there for a second I need to go right
now
Oh God how many holes into the abyss are
there
oh but this is a generator room god damn
it I wasted all my flares - oh god damn
it
I'm so bummed I gotta shoot this guy and
I don't know how I'm gonna be able to
get back oh this is just this this must
be what hell is like I gotta shoot him
there's no other way there's no other
way right there's no other way all right
here we go
there you go he's dead alright that was
the only way to get by that guy and
really I didn't want to shoot him but
hey I have no other choice to progress
the story I may not get the good ending
I've shot a lot of those buggers oh crap
what is that
who's that over there there was an
accident oh god why does everything have
to be locked literally everything on
this whole place is locked up tight
uhh
goddamn where are they ah piss they're
right there
god damn it oh I have no more flares I
have nothing I have me anything was it
you guys told me to take a green pills
one minute swallows tasted funny I feel
sleepy fall asleep right here man just
do it
fall asleep right here I'm gonna have to
shoot these guys there's no other way
around it premiere [ __ ] let me just
reload yo all right we're good no no no
no what are you doing Paul your gun
you dumbass
ow ow ow there we go
all right they're dead I did it I didn't
want to did it but I had to did it it's
just it was Oh what is that sound
I had to you through him I am just I am
cocking up everything around here I am
breaking everything I'm [ __ ] around I
need to get back home because I need to
sleep because I'm about to dog goddammit
yup
no I need to get to that mirror you
[ __ ] why are you all angry why are you
still angry that was going on over here
ah why are you still angry stop being so
angry at me I need to get home and sleep
where's the uh oh okay here we go
all right look deeply into it I haven't
checked on the director in a while
maybe there's something that I could get
out of him I would really love some more
flares but I haven't been able to get
let me check the frequency 102.5 drew
director come on I got something special
in store for you today
cool now do I have to go check out now
I'm gonna do that I don't think I'm
gonna die on the way there if I do I'm
pretty pathetic aren't I
I'll probably die on the way there yeah
I'm probably gonna die let's just be
honest let's be honest okay so this one
I needed to place the rotting no no no
rotting me place down hunka me but in
the hiding spot gegege these guys exist
a son of a [ __ ] 24/7 always on my back
never working always lazy your flinch
scrawny bastards oh he's eating all my
food even my rotten food how dare you
look is it laziest of them all just
laying there waiting for something to
happen but it never does is he so so
sorry didn't mean that I apologize
sincerely are you being such a lazy sack
of crap legged twitching all over the
place
just dancing non-stop I swear when I
become leader this done I'm gonna ban
all dancing hey Ted Danson a box it get
it's get out here all right there we go
yeah yeah yeah yada yada yada
go to the director where is he we get
him but um boom I'm hungry
well you're gonna have to deal with it
maybe the director has some food for you
come here I can't see straight how about
you stop complaining I found this in
thought of you a cattle alright that's
good
can find some coffee used to like coffee
before this all happened way before what
happened all the same don't overdo it
look after yourself kid well thanks
director now that I think on it how
about something to light your way he's
got a bunch of flares can trade them for
ammo oh no three flares for ten bullets
anger to you gimme the mo if you decide
verse three flares are on the house yeah
I've just used some V V director oh geez
sorry man
thanks the director oh this is gonna be
sis I am messing with ya ah don't be so
uptight kid
catch you later then alright so if I
pretty sure you will are you done
talking now alright so the deal is if I
give him ammo I've got plenty of ammo
I would love to trade ammo for flares I
would love to not have to kill anyone
okay I think I can do that again but
I've got six flares do I really want to
sigh alright let's do this I'll have
nine flares which should be more than
enough to go back and forth between guys
as much as I want right that's the
objective here you're losing it here
just hold on for a little bit more
where's that mirror I know there's a
mirror
wait a minute just went into the oh
there's a mirror down the hall that's
right it's not in this areas no don't
hide there's no reason to hide can't go
on much longer just deal with it and huh
what if I what if I give you some I give
you some prawn crackers how about that
munch on those of it hmm much better you
actually looking better now you can see
better now huh I didn't know that was a
thing okay let's just go get to the
mirror get out of here oh no wait no I'm
not gonna get to the mirror because I
need to keep the mirror in store for the
other location so I'm just gonna have to
hoof it from here not that far anyways
going on the homework yes I killed way
too many of them didn't know where'd you
come from oh do I have to take the
mirror ah fudge nutters no I don't wait
a minute no I don't I'm an idiot I'm an
idiot I'm just an idiot you guys are
probably always yelling at me about how
big of an idiot I am and it's true I am
an idiot there's right here I've seen
worse I don't think that other guy
patrolled enough so that I was going to
be able to get away from him
and I need to sleep anyway Lee Beesley
Beasley Beasley Beasley I have a huge
bing-bong bing-bong
oh I'm back here alright then hello mr.
box head
hello again did you figure it out yet
why I chose choose to wear a box ha ha
ha
to hide that's what miss tall shake does
not as stupid and answer as it sounds
what about your ugly was that a dumb
answer I think you need a helping hand
you really must eat your greens you're
talking green pills I'm assuming that's
what he's talking about
ok game save please yes and actually
save this time because you didn't before
now I gotta make my way down to the
basement but I don't know if Sun Oh
before I do that I'm definitely gonna
stock up on stuffer nutters rotten meat
there we go look alright now I'm gonna
use a stove to cook some delicious ham
instant coffee brew it all
need water yes where the hell am I gonna
get water uh yes I have no idea now I'm
all at a loss I don't have anything to
cook well I'll go wasted time where am I
gonna get one oh no what are you doing
said I have a bucket that's right and
there was some dripping water but I
don't remember where was it in my home
was the dripping water in my home I
don't think uh it was it's right there
oh it was oh man I'm such a genius I'm
so - genius bucket use but I am come
back when it's full oh all right then
fine if that's how it's gonna be I guess
I have no other choice I don't really
have a choice in the matter now do i I
don't have a choice in a lot of things
damn it I gotta get to the other side
uh which was a better route the left or
the right I'm gonna go left
just to see what's up this does not
sound like the better choice I recall ah
whoa I don't even see you there
Oh give me a heart attack man okay right
was a better choice I'm Liz Lemon slap
me if I'm not affected already
definitely I'm gonna be soon huh oh yeah
I got the series of hidey-holes that's
right I got plenty of rotten meat to do
this so ooh you got you yes kaboosh
Turkey all right now there's a whole
bunch of them here so I got a I got a
place that's why yeah yeah that's right
since it didn't save I guess these guys
didn't get killed and ergo I might have
a chance at still getting in a good
ending hey that's actually not bad I can
live with this okay now uh
oh where am I Wow I was being hit the
whole time you're gonna be checking me
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no no no no
no no no no where am I oh God
at least I just saved oh that's such
baloney then he said that is this much
baloney that is like maximum blog 'no
tude
although i do love this title screen
music it's very nice oh that was such
baloney i was being murdered and I
couldn't even see it
this is why man like I'm an out for ages
it's like you've been dead for ages how
about that
Oh such bull honkey alright I'm just
gonna have to get past these guys I
don't know how to get past that last one
oh I've got flares ah oh no did I stock
up on meat
I got enough okay I got enough alright
places down baby Ida holy Patti in my
hidey hole hello you're looking awfully
swell today have you been working out
and then place this one here and then
what I'm gonna hide what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna quickly get out of flare once
I get past this guy and plop it down and
run right past him cuz I'm such a badass
ignited Boosh yeah wait which way did I
need to go oh there was a mirror in
there that I didn't use
but either way yeah down into the
basement of doom alright so my choice is
to go down the central hallway to that a
question mark marked down which is what
I shoulda done a while ago but I've been
totally totally flabbergasted at the
interpretations I don't even know if I
have enough battery to get through here
okay so I just got to get past these
[ __ ] where are these [ __ ] anyway
I see one all right let me just prep the
flare up ya got eight flares plenty of
flares right I'm gonna go to his maximum
they're grouped up together which means
that I can place this no no no I didn't
got it cool huh what's in here what's in
here what's in there Oh Olli did the
monsters do this is there something in
someone inside there don't really want
to stick around long enough to find out
uh-oh last night
Oh No am I out of batteries oh I might
be out of batteries nope oh okay
turn it off turn it off go down the
hallway we're almost at our place okay
we just need to go check this door here
doors rusted shut I hear some things
Auggie's we're doing good where are you
I don't see you hey one oh this is not
where I want to be that's not where I
want to be
I hear it I don't see it oh it's closed
oh I don't see it huh let me just turn
up the game a bit oh that doesn't help
oh I'll turn on my flashlight just
really ah ooh but at least they were
grouped together so that means that I'll
be able to place down a flare and get
them both hopefully oh god are they
close no enemies okay okay
where are you [ __ ] he's down close
but I don't know how close oh oh oh oh
okay place down the flare but not it ah
no no that's not what I wanted oh crap
well what do I do here okay I just got a
place down a flare and boogie on out
right whoa whoa whoa he doesn't make it
no no there's something on the floor
over there than I need I'm just gonna
place a flare and hopefully grab it in
time got a handgun to him oh that was it
well it looks like I'm up put your hand
inside it okay here goes going out a lot
of time generator key all right yeah
yeah we're doing great you're doing
great so far
live in fantastical at the generator
okay I see the outlines of the sons of
[ __ ]
get this where's oh god where's my flare
where's my flare my flare where's my
flares where's my flares we're all there
there here we go huh goodbye sayonara
cha cha cha ha kiss kiss kiss gah
what is that okay ground espresso oh
wait no yeah god damn it I gotta go all
the way around kissing balls Oh God not
these guys again I'm going to literally
run out of flares before I get through
exactly Oh God where are they where are
they they sound really close how close
are they exactly uh I don't want to look
at the espresso I went out the flares
ready to go good dick bagger oh I see
him okay
nighttime Boosh maybe they just
automatically get everyone in the
hallway and I don't even need to worry
about getting close to him I'm probably
just playing this way to dangerously
aren't I
okay now I think I killed the ones over
here so yeah I should just be able to go
right down I believe anyway where am I
mm I don't hear anything
did I kill all these [ __ ] I killed
everyone oh I killed everyone oh that's
that's not that's going to reflect
poorly on my record there's a chasm
ahead okay here's the generator it
worked
I used a generator key good for me I'm
such a winner in life oh this doesn't
look good argh
oh my head that was happening what's
going on help me someone anyone help me
my head is pounding
ooh that's Brian I probably shouldn't
add my light on for this oh there I go
I've checked out Oh what what's going on
how did I get here nothing makes much
sense anymore am i dead is this what it
feels like
I'm missing confused as you are guys
is this somewhere from my past who are
you
you really don't remember me I'm not
sure
come on you I know you're just teasing
really he always used to tease me like
that I've never seen you before
must be dreaming this very funny you
anyway I'm glad you took me here it's
been a long time since we left the city
it looks so far away from here yeah it
does I've forgotten what it felt like
peaceful Oh
now when's it gonna turn horrible you
know we should play that game we used to
play I'll run off and count it you count
to like a million then you come and find
me doesn't sound like a very fun game
and if you really can't find me I'll
wait for you here how's that sound
sounds like fun does it does it really
does it really sound like fun mister
well there you have it then I'm waking
up now what's happening to me I I have
to get out of here
I can't take much more I don't blame you
kid I don't blame you at all
get a grip you pull yourself together
man you're stronger than this yeah so
strong okay so where are we now we in
the generator room what was that
irradiated orange why is it irradiated I
need to use something with it exhausted
pretty ancient doubted that it's safe
think it's something to do with the
generator maybe use board
okay so the fuel pipe and turn off my
thingy for a second here I know that I
have some tools here
can opener scissors saucepan flashlight
and a can opener don't have anything to
use um well golly gee miss do you don't
seem to have anything to use yet uh how
about the schizos let's just can't
opener uh geezers good uh how about you
use it uh the saucepan um the cat lush
I'm not talk to the cat plush I'm not
entirely sure what I'm supposed to do
here I don't think I have anything maybe
if I cut something from the fuse board
or rule that just kill myself no damn it
okay um i reaiiy need like a wrench or
something but I don't know where to get
that very confused okay there's a chasm
well this this sucks cuz I'm just back
where I started I haven't turned it on
at all I haven't done anything to help
me I guess I gotta go down that hallway
and go down into the cellar area I guess
good thing to know that it everything is
dead on the way there
some murdering bastard I am gonna be
very upset if it proves it at the end of
all this it actually was all these
people were real and that I'm just a
psychotic murderer as opposed to
anything else
flares ready where are they okay they're
there
Oh God
come on come here come here come here
come here come here come here Gary ago
goddamn that's a close one huh I thought
it was gonna die okay
oh [ __ ] yeah go down here okay here we
go what's courts cellar oh that's not a
good figure sound I don't at least I
don't hear any of those things need food
or we'll get food in a bit or we'll get
food now
don't eat the rotting meat man how about
the fruit salad sounds good
been waiting for this it's delicious and
it's got vitamin C to prevent scurvy I
go in here yes oh there's a mirror here
hey sweet all right
that's fantastic I probably should save
soon I probably should and let me just
explore a bit more I'm pretty sure I
won't die maybe oh that's a different
noise that is a difference down in here
okay pan gun ammo
that'll do I'll trade that for some
flares oh this is empty in here and
what's about here not gonna open but
here that thing look different there's
room isn't fun
Oh No Oh what did I do
no oh no oh no oh no oh no I'm doomed
I'm doomed I'm doomed turn off my light
Oh pick up what's up new batteries just
turn off your light oh it won't turn off
oh no no no no oh oh no oh no oh no oh
my god I there I didn't save you didn't
give me a chance to save what are you
doing stop turn off your light I don't
know if it's off or on
oh there we go that thing is different
though I'm gonna go I'm gonna go back
home screw this screw everything about
this screw this place screw it all the
hell this place is awful this place
deserves to be written down into the
deepest depths of Hell into the deepest
depths of Hell I'm gonna do one last
thing before I go to sleep so I'm gonna
take green pill you guys said I need to
take green pills well I don't know what
that did to me feel a little drowsy it's
pounding it's gonna sleep love its new
use well hopefully this didn't murder me
murder me dead
hello mr. box head man
will you take that goddamn box off your
head already
I can't be expected to do that can i
otherwise why would they call me the man
who wears a box they call you that it's
not your real name like anyone would
call you that
you're right about something now start
thinking oh right in the kisser
about what shame you need this but here
it is darkness is infectious what did I
get what did I get what did you give me
I needed that
what did I get what did I get did I get
batteries maybe he gave me batteries
good all right the game is saved and
hopefully it actually did save this time
so anyway I'll continue this series I'll
try to beat it in longer episodes much
faster so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
should we
turns